y para el escudo y cuando el gobierno
anunció señores allegados
no sabemos de ivette arellano de 57 años
está entre los 170 mil bolivianos que se
han quedado sin completar su esquema de
vacunación contra el cob y 19 porque
rusia ha incumplido con el envío de la
segunda dosis de la spu tikvá la tengo
que hacer operar y por esta vacuna
espera 90 días y ahora me encuentro en
una situación de lo negro colgando que
no sé a dónde me voy a dirigir el
presidente luís arce recibió la primera
dosis de la misma vacuna el 24 de mayo y
este mes debería tocarle la segunda ante
las críticas minimizó el impacto de la
falta de la expo tikvá en el plan de
vacunación sin embargo de ello la
expotec se presenta sólo el 25 por
ciento del stock de vacunas que llegó a
nuestro país el 75 por ciento es de
otras vacunas y por lo tanto están
garantizadas
esta es la segunda vez que el instituto
estatal ruso gama ley a proveedor del
sputnik en cumple con el envío de la
segunda dosis de su vacuna el colegio
médico critica que se juegue con la
salud de la gente que gamal ella en su
primera intervención decía 21 días y
había que colocar la segunda dosis para
potencializar luego solamente nos han
indicado de que había estudios para que
se coloquen 90 días y ahora se sale con
180 días y eso es algo que creo que no
se puede jugar con la salud
bolivia y rusia tienen varios proyectos
de desarrollo en común pero en el tema
de las vacunas la afinidad ideológica no
ha impedido los problemas en el
cumplimiento del contrato una falla que
ha dejado en la incertidumbre a miles de
personas sobre todo de la tercera edad
cuando se teme una eventual cuarta ola
del 419